ああああああ
par
me
[音楽]
1010年
1月
配置大震災
31万人の死者が出ました
2011年3月東日本大震災
や行方不明者合わせて約2万人が亡くなりました
その後私は2011年の5月
医療支援活動のため配置迎えます
当時の配置の人です
至る所にこのような
避難民のキャンプがありました
その時の私はこの配置の
歯医者大流行していたこれらの治療キャンプにいます
多くの患者がこのように
ベッドに寝かされ点滴の治療を受けています
これらと言う病気は
先進国では
そんななくなるような病気ではないんです
しっかりして点滴と飲料水を飲んでいくことで治療できるからです
ところがこの配置の病棟では
すでに
空になったボトル点滴ボトルにつながれた患者さん
そういったものも多数に生けられ
日本と比べると
適切な管理ができているとはいえません
まだ寝ている方は幸運な方かもしれません
これは
治療スペースがないために
椅子に座って点滴を受けている人たちも
その写真です
悲惨な状況です
日本とは大きく違うことが見て取れるかと思います
皆さん
この状況どう思われます
そして週末には
よく人が死ぬんです
なぜかわかりますか
医者が休みだからです
スタッフの3割程度が休むからですよ
つまりその間に治療を受けられない適切な治療を受けられない人は
死ぬんです
私がそこで感じたのは
怒りという
そういう感情だったと思いますなんとかすればこの現実を変えれるんじゃないのか
もっと頑張れば買えるんじゃないだろうか
そういった思いです
そしてこの配置で
結核の病院に私は拘りました
この瞬間に私の人生は変わったんだと思います
なぜなら
この現場を見てしまったからなんです
感じてしまったからなんです
震災の後でしたので
の配置では
結果軍兵棟が倒壊して
1年以上も店頭での診療が続いていました
その中で私は1人の患者さんの説明を
聞いていたんですね
この人はこういう人だとそうかそうかと聞いていたところ
少し遠くの方に
すごく外見の気になる患者さんが寝ていることに気付いたんです
何だろうと思ったんですここから見ているとまるで
皮膚が後動いているようなそんな印象を受けたんですよ
んだろうと思いました
そして私は
ちょっと近寄っていって
その患者さん見たんですね
無数のハエが
カルン
全身に集っているんです
それがその理由でした
回復することは
ないだろうなというような状態でした
意識もなかったかなと
思っています
皆さん
はいバー
よく知っているんです
これから死んでいく人
唯一
この現場で
変わらないかなと思ったのは
やはり
森羅1
3タートの家族です
私は日本の医者として
この現場で自分の力を役に立てようと
そう思って実はこの現場にい疑問で行ったんです
ですが現実は
点滴の一つスラー
することができなかったそういうなくなっていく人に点滴をするようなことを
医療物資も限られているので出来ません
彼の呼吸は徐々に弱まって
背部ような
呼吸になり呼吸が止まり
溝こともありました
彼は占めました
何もできなかったと言う
そこで感じたのが
私は無力だなということだった
ここから
2年の時間をかけて
現在認定 npo 法人となった future コードという団体を立ち上げます
そして2013年の6月
配置で初めての結果区の無料検診
ようやく実現することができたんですもちろん目的は
患者さんの早期森羅の機会を提供することそして命を守ることです
もちろんこのプログラムがすごくうまくいったときつまり患者さんがちゃんと治療でき
て治療まで結びつけられた時ですね診断してから
でもそれだけじゃないですよねすごく不安に思っている方もいるんですもしかしたら
自分は結核かもしれないって
でも検査のした結果
今のところ大丈夫そうです私が入った時に喜んで帰ってくれるっていう
これも一つの大きな喜びでした
でもそれだけじゃないですね
やはり現実は少し違う
検査をしていると
どうしても
結核じゃないけどもっと重い病気の珍客あるよ見てき例えばがんとかですこういう病気
を見つけてしまうことがあります
でもこれ以上詳しい検査もこの場所でできないんです
国は日本とは違うんだっていうことは私も頭では分かっていたはずです
でも目の前いるこの患者さんたちは
遠い場所から私たちを頼って
そしてここで検査を受けて
そう言って来てくれた人達だとわかっていますその人たち
私は
県産結果を袋にしまって
塩渡しながら
結核ではない
そう思いますが
何らかの病気があるようです
在来の
先生に相談してくださいと言って
渡すんです
これ以上治療が
行われないということを知りながら
2011年の
10月には
私はトルコの東部地震という地震が起こりまして600人が約600人が亡くなった
自信ですがここに緊急医療チームの一人として派遣されていました
ここにはバス得られない話があります
この場所は到底も寒い場所でした車
とても寒かった
レイドで吹雪や雨が降りそういう場所です
しかしながら余震が起こるので建物の中に止まるわけにいかなかった
テントの中で我々 nedo の1たんですけどその点と
やっぱり体力もすごく消耗するので
離れた場所に
宿泊施設に泊まることにしたんですそれで地元のドライバー
クルド人のドライバーをやだったんですね
彼は決まった時間に送迎してくれてこの医療現場まで私たちを連れて行ってくれたん
です
そんな中で一つの事件が起こるんです
宿泊施設の中で
彼が人目をはばからず号泣してるんですよ
私は
彼に動作のかと
訪ねたんです
すると
この医療現場は他社がやってる現場のそばにある場所
ここから彼の息子が遺体で見つかったんです
私は
彼に家族の元に戻るように撮っ
いいました
同時に私は
調整員に新しいドライバーを至急見つけてほしいと頼みました
やはり私も明日からの活動をしなければならないという責任を感じていたからなんです
が
でもやはり
新しいドライバーが自ら保証もなく
多少不安にも思いながら何の連絡もなかったそのまま次の日の朝を迎えたんです
そうしたら次の日の朝パッと下に降りてみると
その彼がドライバーが立ってたんですよ
能大丈夫かとなんでここにいる家族の元に戻らなくていいのがあって私聞いたんですね
そしたら彼はや仕事をするんだ
いきませんでした
そのままチームは活動を続けます
そして
最終日に
彼の
ところに行って
あなたの大切な時間
私たちのために使ってくれてありがとこと
そう言ったら
彼は
スーッと静かに
泣きながら
ありがとう等
いいました
今では私たちの一つの活動地あるバングラディシュ
2017年今年の9月にあったことです
この連カルシウム40歳くらいの方です
は日本で働いたこともある方で日本語もすごく上手で私たちスタッフにも日本人にも
とても敬意をもって話してくれて
そして
日本のことを尊敬していると
言ってくれていました
ところが出会ったのはやはり病室ですもし日本で彼が行けたならば
診断されたならばこう有名じゃなかったと思うんです
彼は数ヶ月ないからもう体調が悪かった
いろんな病院を転々としてたんですでも
診断も治療もなかなかされていなかったんです
バングラディッシュは近年すごく発展してきましたそれでもやはりまだこういう悪性
疾患癌とかですね
こういうものに対する診療はまだまだ伸びていないところがあります
私も彼の病状できるだけ把握しようと
頑張ったんですがわかったのは元が彼の背骨に
10しているということだけでした急いで治療計画も考えたんですけど
すぐに彼らの病状悪化して激しいためがすげーしました
その痛みの中で私も痛みをなんとか撮ろうと
やっていろんな薬を調達して明日から予約開始となった
その日の夜に
彼が激しいための中で死んでいったことを聞かされました
誰のせいでもないのかもしれないですこういう状況
でも残った家族に私はいろいろ考えてくれてありがとうと言われたとき
返す言葉はなかったッ
2016年の10月
ここは西アフリカブルキナファソです
私たちはここで蚊が媒介する病気マラリア
この病気と水と衛生の改善こういうプログラムを現地に導入するためにここにいました
ここはマラリアの大流行地です
マラリアというのは2000年以降ずいぶん激減したんですか
それでもまだ子どもたちの命を奪う重要な病気です
皆さんこのブルキナファソの平均寿命ってご存知ですか
58歳です
そして私たちが活動するこのが場所では
10人に1人の子どもは5歳まで生きることができません
病院に来るのも大変です
例えばいろんな問題があります貧困
距離が遠いこれだけでもず病院に来るのは大変なんです
それでもない医者にこういう子供が
医療機関を受診して治療が行われていますそして私はついこの前
五歳の子供の診察を頼まれました
まだ元気だったんですその時は肺炎もなかった
日本だったまあ普通の風邪だったらいけるかなと思ったんですが
翌週
この殺しみました
実はこのとき
普通ならばマラリアの薬は無料で提供されるんですけどこの時政府が財政難でマラリア
の薬の提供が止まってたんです
無理があるべきはずの店には
何もありませんでした
運命だったのかもしれませんそう言えるかもしれません
私はまた見守るしかできなかったなと
しかしながら
沢山の無力を感じてきましたが
今日から5日後
私は
再びバングラディッシュを迎えます
ありがとうございました
[拍手]